peint surtout une question pour oliver
stone j'aimerais qu'ils nous parlent de
la plaisir un peu paradoxal qu'il ya
dans le film semble-t-il a filmé la
beauté des visages féminins et de les
mettre en face à face en vis-à-vis avec
une terreur absolue représenté là aussi
donc d'un côté ça ce grand grande beauté
la beauté aussi des corps des jeunes
gens et de l'autre une terreur extrême
et oui ce type d'action plage et sims in
one durable 2009 et touche abbasside
frenchy qu'est ce que c'est français
cette façon de commencer toutes les
questions par le mot paradoxe agace
souvent je crois non je crois mais oui
peut-être le mot dichotomie c'est vrai
que c'est un mot très bien john oui
c'est vrai aussi un dico du paradoxe pas
seulement les femmes pas seulement les
femmes assassinées film de brian de
palma
non pourquoi pas déjà moi j'aime bien
beaucoup j'ai beaucoup de j'ai beaucoup
de pauses sommes dans mes films avec des
peaux corps et ils sont tués
donc dans les guerres tout ça ici aussi
il ya des jeunes
une fois les mois j'ai mené deux femmes
qui sont fortes dans ce film et j'adore
d'achat elle trouve un substitut tout
une fille une fille qui la parlent don
blake et ouais et blake ressort des
sentiments pour sa fille mais je vois je
comprends pas la question parce que je
vois ça dans tous ses films
autre question micro et ici j'ai une
question pour salma y pour john c'était
pour savoir justement ces personnages
qu'ils interprètent différentes facettes
parce qu'ils nous font aussi rires il ya
de l'humour
comment vous les avez préparé à ce qu il
ya une part personnelle ou est-ce que
c'est beaucoup de discussions avec
oliver qui a permis tout ça en même
temps j'aimerais savoir ce que vous
pensez de vos partenaires et trois
jeunes acteurs principaux
parce qu'on peut dire qu'on les découvre
aussi avec ce film sur ne connaissais
pas merci mansion amine characters i so
you feel
fais une en fait je crois mais je fais
confiance à mes instincts dire quel que
soit le personnage que je joue au cinéma
c'est un peu le yin et le yang cette
espèce d'équilibré à trouver entre
effectivement le côté dramatique d'un
personnage et puis évidemment l'humour
c'est à la limite je dirais que dan s
est un peu et est un peu le moment
comique du faste un personnage qui
permet en tout cas la respiration qui
permet le rire parce que avant et après
lui
en général c'est la tension ou le chaos
donc lorsqu'il apparaît le public le
spectateur est prêt à sourire et un rire
parlant je pense à cette scène où
évidemment on poignante comme ça de sa
main et là évidemment c'est complètement
ridicule
mais soudain il parle de son titre
soudain ça devient un agent fédéral
alors qu'en réalité il est dans une
situation désespérée que l'argent de la
drogue est là et là soudain une seule
chose compte qu'il met en avant c'est
son titre
évidemment que c'est ridicule ça ne veut
rien dire ce titre là à ce moment là
mais c'est ce qui me permet à chaque
fois dans des scènes de trouver ce juste
équilibre entre effectivement le sérieux
et le rire la crise ben oui oui
d'ailleurs lorsque la première fois que
l'on voit des nes à l'écran il est en
train de bouffer vraiment un peu commun
comme un cochon j'ai pas très propre sur
lui et tout de suite
c'est une façon d'inviter justement les
spectateurs à se dire tiens je sais qui
c'est lui et donc à à vraiment se
focaliser ensuite sur l'histoire en
moins de gens du
c'est moi et au spa 12h00 oui c'est par
exemple le moment où obéniche del toro
vient pour menacer effectivement des
naissent alors à la fois on a ce mélange
de dialogue qui est finalement assez
drôle et alors que dan et c'est en train
de supplier bénéchou de ne pas le tuer
et cette scène d'ailleurs été assez
difficile au départ on n'arrivait pas
vraiment à trouver le bon rythme
et soudain j'ai dit j'ai dit à john
écoute
voilà ce que tu dois faire imagine que
benicio c'est un serpentin cobra qu'il
est rentré dans ton salon est ta survie
est bien c'est de le fixer de ne jamais
le quitter des yeux
quoi que tu fasses quoi que tu dises
tue-le tue-le fixe du regard tu tourne
autour de lui mais tu ne le quitte
jamais du regard et à ce moment là
john justement à a changé en quelque
sorte son jeu le sérieux et le côté donc
plus dramatiques de la scène est arrivé
à ce moment là parce qu'il y avait cet
équilibre est ce parallélisme entre un
dialogue plutôt drôle et tout le sérieux
et l'intensité dans le regard de john
sang my way où elle battu à une radio
locale radio proto de gaza
de caractère ou de notre famille a
demandé with no name is not as
charismatique la caf to say it's hot
chasse pêche alpes les chariots no to be
par toche31 d'adieu ses adversaires de
cette idée le cloud and urban rider et
nikos hewitt titre voici une trés sting
bonne note pour être beautiful cents
soit la date n'ont pas de comédie in à
caractère de trois dates des spin boldak
lui plaît les spécialistes du mexique à
14 dervis a tragic pipeau bottes des
livres neufs vérité qui le souhaitent d
existence
it's you yous les ridiculise tout lives
in house by appris ça il au bio
hoste et johan house est une espèce
animale et de fanny domingo bifani
un des ex-managers comédie trop de
caractère a dit notre ado des missiles
en pologne au livre du working to that
in one thing obligatoires nao a
playground ce qu'airbus et se connaît
tous tapis pour une sinistrose
alors d'abord je regarde j'ai pas eu
énormément de scènes effectivement avec
jordan et c'est donc pas beaucoup de
répétitions donc c'est vrai que lorsque
j'ai découvert le film j'ai vu le
travail extraordinaire le jeu de
comédien à l'écran parce que sur la page
dans le scénario le personnage de dan et
ce n'était pas si drôle que ça pas si
charismatique même
donc c'était je dois vous dire que
vraiment faire ce film tourné si mike
henry veut avec des acteurs comme john
et et les autres c'est un plaisir
vraiment très particulier alors vous
savez d'habitude quand je tourne un film
j'ai une idée assez précise de ce qu'il
va donner à l'écran là pas du tout j'ai
eu cette surprise extraordinaire de
découvrir savage 2 et c'est très
excitant parce que je me suis rendu
compte à quel point enlève nous avait
tous inspirés et donc nous avez rendus
inspirant à travers un scénario qui
certes était intéressant mais qui
n'avait pas toutes ses subtilités là
soudain j'ai découvert un film qui était
politique et est sensuelle où il y avait
vraiment des éléments qui avaient été
créés pendant le tournage
alors vous parliez de l'humour de mon
personnage faut que je vous dise l'année
les cartels au mexique n'y a rien de
sont des gens qui vivent des vies plutôt
triste voire tragique est en tout cas
ridicule franchement est ce que vous
imaginez vous êtes dans ces immenses
maisons seul
vous êtes un peu comme un prisonnier ou
bien l'otage de votre propre maison avec
pour seule question le matin qu'est ce
que vous allez oui donc évidemment salma
ne voulant pas être tué à son retour
donc parfois c'est pas ils sont pas
aussi ridicule
voilà et donc leur seule préoccupation
c'est qu'elle autres peluches soigner
mal où elles vont ils trouver donc donc
c'est vrai que c'est on n'a pas ce côté
n'est pas exagéré
même si grâce à la recherche que au
réveil la générosité de mettre à notre
disposition
moi je connaissais personnellement
bien des gens qui en tout cas ans
touchés de près ou de loin aux cartels
au mexique
et croyez moi ils sont ce qu'ils sont
très très drôle mais sans le savoir
donc j'ai pris ce personnage très au
sérieux finalement son côté tout match
un peu son côté extravagant et j'ai
adoré un jour à l'aide d'une scène juste
pour vous pour vous donner un exemple
d'abord avec enlèvement il m'autorise
est une prise papus un moment on arrive
sur la scène scène il me dit juste avant
de tourner la prise il dit salma tué
ivre et alors ça m'a dit mais j'ai pas
bu je sale m'a tuer ivre tétouan et ados
que j'ai joué la scène comme évidemment
rendez vous me le demandez
j'avais un peu peur parce que je me suis
dit est-ce qu'on va vraiment comprendre
que je suis ivre puisqu'on n'a jamais vu
boire ou bien ce qu'on va me prendre
pour une mauvaise actrice et puis j'ai
fait la scène une prise en rêvait
étaient ravis voilà la scène qui suivent
il a cette fois ci c'est la scène où je
suis vous savez où je tiens le cheval
par la laisse et sa fameuse réplique si
mohamed ne vient pas extérieur et là on
le veut se tourner vers moi et me dis là
tu n'es pas ivre tu es encore plus ivre
lajunie m'enfin les voeux on n'a pas
encore vu bon c'est pas grave tu es de
plus en plus vivre et tu le montre et en
fait je me suis rendu compte que
personne ne m'avait jamais s'était
jamais demandé pourquoi je jouais la
scène comme ça donc et agent de rajouter
aussi il ya une aussi à un moment très
très fort et drôle en même tant qu'hôtel
d'iao il ya quelque chose de de tordu de
foutu avec ton histoire d'amour avec les
deux jeunes gens voilà
question une question que pour l'hiver
stone encore il y a une vingtaine
d'années avec quelques tueurs nés on a
l'impression que c'était la violence qui
a choqué l'amérique
dans ce film là on a l'impression que
c'est plus peut-être aujourd'hui le
ménage à trois la liberté sexuelle de
ces trois gènes qui pourraient la choqué
est ce que pour vous c'était cessé quand
cela est un moyen aussi de mettre le
point nous mettre le doigt pardon sur
justement ce le ridicule du puritanisme
actuelle américains savaient jazz et 6
mai be with me et le sexe so what
deux américains premièrement je fais pas
les films pour choquer voyager pas
mongole je fais des films pour trame
trouver une vérité qui ne qui est
peut-être un orthodoxe qu'on ne sait pas
encore
oui c'est bon une bonne idée de trouver
un un scénario avec une fille et deux
hommes et c'est et se tait sa sur les
américains qui voient pas beaucoup ça
ils ont vu dans butch cassidy inde
inscrits mais la fille et rcd en fin de
compte il faisait l'amour mais ils ont
pas montré hésité c'était subsistait
sujet sté en 69 kg et qui était choquant
dans ce cas mais non c'est pas le film
n'était pas fait pour deux chambres
s'étaient fait pour chasser une vérité
qui est devenu de la guerre de drogue a
rendu les gens dans cet état qui sont
alors ces six histoires dont le mot
différents se cherche pas à choquer
c'est pas mon corps s'est donné un bon
histoire dramatique bien fait c'est tout
ce que je veux vraiment oui
oui oui oui oui
ouais c'est oui mais en numérique tu
sais il ya des origines c'est très
difficile de faire des choses comme ça
en france ce serait beaucoup plus
amusant de faire un film de une fille et
deux garçons quelque chose comme ça en
france vous avez beaucoup plus de
liberté vous n'êtes pas puritain amical
comme les hypocrites comme l'amérique
mais c'est très dur le mec mais aussi
avec des drames
c'est ridicule qu'on met des personnes
en prison pour fumer de la marijuana
c'est qu'est ce que tu veux que ça saute
ça se fait tout à l'envers c'est tout à
l'envers
voilà et enfin dernière question qui a
le micro lascaux à ce jour une question
pour oliver stone s'il vous plaît vous
aviez il ya quelques années un projet
sur le général noriega qui sait pas
faire qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire
et est-ce que vous avez recycler une
partie de votre frustration dans ce film
avec des similitudes thématiques ou
autres noms des deux opus de mamies dans
les bacs et moi alors j'ai dit oui oui
scène mais retient 800 points ce week
end
samedi prochain
ok alors voilà d'abord bien sûr j'ai
rencontré noriega et on a essayé à
l'époque de faire un film qui serait un
peu un film satirique parce que
évidemment c'est à settat c'est un
personnage qui a une vie incroyable il
était évidemment alliés des américains
avec les contrats pour déstabiliser le
nicaragua c'est un c'est un personnage
qui est complexe et multiple gels et
j'ai été le voir en prison à miami
ensuite il était en france puis les
retourner au panama peut être sorti at
il un jour de prison je ne sais pas mais
justement l'ours copains et de noriega
bien c'est ça la guerre contre la drogue
c'est tout simplement politique lorsque
l'on parle de colombie le mexique du
panama et bien chaque fois c'est une
façon d'envoyer dans ces pays
des espions des militaires des pilotes
ex terrain qui en fait au nom de la
guerre contre la drogue en réalité sont
là pour mettre ces pays sous
surveillance pour ailleurs qu on les
appelle les narcos states donc tout ça
c'est en fait à une question politique
il s'agit des états unis qui veulent
finalement à travers le faux problème
dans la guerre de la drogue et bien
exercer un contrôle sur ces pays
évidemment c'est très dangereux donc
bien sûr noriega n'était pas un
personnage n'est pas un personnage
reluisant mais peut-être un jour
d'ailleurs fera t-on un film sur lui
peut-être le ferai je ne sais pas où
peut-être faudrait-il faire un vrai film
sur la guerre contre la drogue et c'est
peut-être un film que je ferai un jour
merci à vous tous merci ça en a
c'est alors quoi
en
ap